oh do you got an album on the way I know
you dropped the album a couple years ago
album on the way but I'm dropping
singles I just did some Regional remixes
with a couple people like I saw you did
the sped up version of this song which
seems to be like everyone's got the like
yeah the like Club Music version of
their songs like the Jersey type of vibe
going on yeah that's that's going crazy
on Tick Tock but I did some remixes with
uh Lakayla from the bay
and I did one with Kenzo bishi's from
New York I'm doing one with little Tyler
coming up and talk to him yeah he's so
he's so cool and he's a kid and I was in
there I was in a nightclub with him
recently
and I just looked over and I was like
why are you supposed to be here
at least I think he's 16 or 17. yeah I
think he's not 18 or not even 18. I was
like why is he in here because he's cool
right he gang so you already did that
version yeah well it hasn't dropped yet
but it's on the way and then uh sexy red
I did one with her too it's coming so
I'm trying to that's got to be a very
very uh provocative song no actually
it's not provocative she was just
talking her her ones I'm interviewing
her today really yeah okay yeah
sexy red she's a
she's free yeah we love we love the
girls that's free I saw her running
around spring break with the breakfast
is out I said hey
are you a fan of Pound Town do you like
this yes yeah I love found town
yeah it's a it's a good song yeah
I feel like you do like like you're
because I think about like some of your
bigger records and they are very like
they're very uh I think that the it
gives me like OG Trina Vibe sometimes
yeah which I feel like has been kind of
missing in in well not really [__] was
kind of that you know but but it kind of
gets did you grow up listening to Trina
at all uh yes and some in some music
yeah who are you bumping as a youngin
um I I like r b Vibes I feel like I was
like listening to like Janae Aiko Okay
and like
um Aaliyah Missy Elliott Vibes like this
was my vibes when you were a kid you
were listening to Janae yeah I'm so old
man
how old are you 22. [__]
what year is that that you were born
2000 I gotta tell you the right huh oh
my God yeah I remember two thousand I
thought what was you doing in 2000 [__]
thinking the world was gonna end at my
uncle's house on New Year's Eve
wait no there was a time in 2020 Y2K
thing that was like a thing like you you
wouldn't know but
when 1999 was happening they said when
the clock hit 2000 like all the
computers and [__] in the world were
gonna like freeze up and like the world
was gonna like end see they that it was
a time in 2012 but they said the same
thing and I was I was 12. and like they
were like it's going to be this big
storm and all this stuff so it was
actually raining that day so I was
having a panic attack like the world is
over with I'm only 12. it's coming yeah
isn't there a movie called 2012. I think
there's a movie yeah really
yeah yeah that's what it was that's what
it was what is your sign
I'm a Leo see I don't know what any of
this means so you just asked it didn't
you so I'm I'm I know I just know I'm an
aquarius okay
look where's they get along well we get
along yeah
Scorpios what months are that like I
don't even know I don't I don't pay
attention score but when you say you're
a Scorpio it's like
um is Drake a Scorpio no Drake's a Libra
no
I think he put out mouth coach
yeah I think he is Scorpio any Scorpios
in here
okay that's good
so if you are like let's say you go out
on a date with a guy and you find out
he's a Scorpio is that a rap
yeah we probably didn't even get along
during the day what if you did get along
and like everything was going great and
then he was like I was born on October
24th and then you're like
yeah they're just full of [__] so
probably really yeah they're sneaky like
it probably went so great and I probably
think the world is like peaches and
creams with them but I just know deep
down there full of [__] really yeah I
you know I didn't know that this existed
like you would like discriminate against
someone you liked because of their I
mean I mean they can't choose that yeah
it depends um
I guess it depends huh it depends on how
good it was like how good the date was I
might considered okay okay yeah uh well
listen man uh shout out to all the
Scorpios out there just know she will
discriminate against you yeah and very
bad and if you work at Amazon you're
[__] don't let you work at Amazon and
be a Scorpio that's the double whammy I
might just walk past you uh what what do
you do in your free time right now are
you like streaming TV are you uh working
out are you playing video games what do
you do when you're on like when you're
not recording or running around the
country pushing your music
um I'm getting into like I love to cook
so I'm trying to start my own little
like cooking
I don't know is it like the reels and
the shows and stuff yeah I'm trying to
you know start doing that I have a dog
we just be at the house I'm kind of
chilling my t-shirt too oh like a little
a little puppy his name is Chase Chase
yeah like that